all right so yeah again thanks to
everyone for for making this possible
and I want to talk to you about this new
assumption the actual assumptions we
need to make that allows us to achieve
IO using the techniques that we've
already seen in the last couple of talks
now the goal of this talk is to tell you
the assumption and for those of you who
have seen sorry there's a technical
issue oh there we go okay for those of
you who've seen me give talks like this
before
you should pay attention nevertheless
because it's a little bit simpler and
really the main goal that we're trying
to do here is to come up with the
simplest plausible assumption hopefully
simplest true assumption that allows us
to attain I owed us sort of the main you
know we should Genda that we're trying
to push here with regard to IO so so
what's the idea as has been alluded to
already we want to leverage the hardness
of solving certain systems of polynomial
equations over the rationals over the
integers okay and we've already talked
about how important I Oh is and why this
is a great problem so let me not mention
that and you know the the the twist that
we're going to be bringing here is that
typically in crypto when we look at
hardness that's present in polynomial
systems we that hardness sort of
critically relies on the mod P structure
right on the fact that we're overflowing
my P and the consequences of that with
regard to trying to solve problems for
example if you're solving systems of
polynomial equations in my P then we
can't do nice things like gradient
descent right so you know these days the
world world and machine learning and
everything works on gradient descent and
you know we've been lucky in crypto that
people can't use that usually to break
our criticisms because we're working my
feet but now we're going to try to
around and track your gonna try to look
at systems of polynomial equations over
the integers where we are now subject to
new attack possibilities and
nevertheless try to find hardness here
and then use it for cryptographic
purposes so that's gonna be what we're
gonna be talking about what's the good
news here the good news is that even the
attack surface is larger you know people
have looked at trying to solve
polynomial systems over the integers and
over the rationals for hundreds of years
it was a very well studied area in
mathematics and so we're not at least
venturing out into completely you know a
strange territory this is not some weird
problem that we're inventing just for
the purpose of building i/o on which you
know arguably is has been the case in
previous works including my own work
trying to build i/o using multiple your
math candidates and things like that
you're trying to really aim for
something that's natural as much as
possible and as you'll see that will
yield an assumption that I'll be able to
present to you in just a single slide
which is sufficient for for building i/o
but it Werner that's slowly sort of
building it up conceptually bit by bit
and again please do stop me and ask
questions at any moment that's very very
helpful to me ok so we want to look at
polynomials or with the integers and
we're looking at in particular we call
expanding systems so that means is that
we have n variables but we'll have n to
the 1 plus epsilon polynomials for
epsilon some small constant think of
like 0.1 and the coefficients of the
polynomials themselves are bounded let's
say ball and bounded by some polynomial
in in okay so this gives us a set of
polynomials Q 1 of X up to QN of X
excuse me and now what we'll do is we'll
choose a vector II uniformly at random
from a subset of the integers let's say
from minus n to n in all of the
coordinates
independently so iid we choose
coordinates from - n - n ok this yield
is a vector e and now what we can do is
we can give the adversary these
polynomials the first just the polymer
observed in terms of their coefficients
queuing up to QN and also the actual
output the actual evaluation of these
polynomials at this planted solution eat
okay and then we're asking the extremely
natural question to start with of
whether the system of polynomial
equations is actually solvable canny
recovery okay and that's the that's
gonna be the inspiration for hardness
that we're gonna be looking at okay so
in the context of IO historically things
like this were implicit in in works that
came earlier where the polynomials were
only degree two and there's some thing
that Rachel alluded to earlier and now
you know why should we hope that maybe
degree two is okay or why did we hope
back then that maybe degree two is okay
well you know if we're willing to make
some sort of analogue to mod P
polynomials it seems reasonable because
if you choose random degree to
polynomials mod p at random and have a
planted solution there's something
called an MQ system that is a bit aside
for a very long time and appears to be
very hard cryptographically we don't
have any good approaches for solving
these things let's say in polynomial
time there are some sub exponential
attacks in certain situations but but if
we're looking for sub-exponential
security this is a very natural thing to
look at unfortunately though as I
mentioned when we're working over the
rationals we were working over this
additional structure that comes from
looking at a subset of the real numbers
then we're subject to an entirely new
attack sort of frontier and that
actually came back to bite us in the
context of such degree two systems and
in a work that that we mentioned earlier
with the barack at all we were able to
use the sum of squares paradigm using
seven different programming certain
kinds of continuous optimization
techniques to actually break such
systems in the sense of being able to
efficiently compute planted solution e
so and it's very interesting that this
is a continuous attack you know this is
an attack that is inherently using
techniques from you know continuous
optimization and I don't want to mention
here that the general case of degree two
solving degree two polynomials with
these kind of average case settings is
actually still open theoretically even
for degree two so we don't have complete
theoretical understanding of degree two
however it is the case that any concrete
degree two candidate polynomial that
we've ever thought of is broken
experimentally using the sum of squares
of a different programming way of
attacking things so we don't know of a
single candidate in degree two that
seems reasonable and so it seems quite
problematic to case so this is the
problem we're not going to be if you
want to look for hardness that exists
over the rationals then degree 2 seems
problematic and this is some sort of
initial warning sign right that
polynomials over the integers are going
to be more complicated and going to
present a more interesting attack
surface than polynomials mod P ok so yes
I have a question
so these higher degree polynomials over
the rationals can in this case
nevertheless nevertheless because of aw
will be expressed as mq over mod p right
like the great su over mod P right but
probably with a different distribution
than considered in classic MQ literature
is that right tell us more about that
yes
I will talk more about that later on
when I get to the elder bluie part of
the talk is it okay yes there's a
question here this - clarification does
the baby cell candidate does it mean
kind of a distribution on polynomials a
good good candidate here means Canada
distribution over polynomials and
distribution over the planted solution
as well okay so so so yes so we are in
the average case there there are no
plausible such distribution that we know
of degree and over degree to where we
can hope for hardness here okay so okay
so again so we have a more complex
attack service we have two nevertheless
the progress so um you know one
important point I want to make sort of
the meta research point of view here is
that you know since do you agree to is
broken we have to add some complexity we
have no option we can't just pretend
that it's secure that's not an option
obviously but we also have to be we have
to remember that we're scientists right
so we should never panic right you know
the panic kind of solution Beauty let's
make things really complicated so that
we could feel safe somehow by how
complicated things look um that's not
right we're not we're not in this for
you know we're not selling a product
tomorrow that we need to convince
someone is secure we're in this for the
basic science for looking at the
fundamentals of building IO so really we
should be trying to do the simplest
thing we can do right we're aiming for
the simplest easiest to state assumption
that we believe is true right so let's
try this simplest thing we can do and so
there's an obvious simple thing to do
which is okay degree two was broken how
about some constant degree that's larger
than two for example three or four or
five or just some other small constant
degree okay
so so we're going to try to do now so
let's fix some constant degree greater
than two and now as the same question
right again I give the adversary the
actual polynomials I give them all the
coefficient
for these end of the 1 plus epsilon
polynomials and n variables again I have
a planted solution that's just chosen
uniformly iid in this way and the
adversary learns the planted the
evaluations of these polynomials at the
planted solution
Kenney recovery what kind of hardness
can be hope for here right so I before
we answer this questions is an average
case you know conjecture that we're
making on you should be asking wait a
second what polynomial it's not it's not
it's not satisfying so they will do
there exist as some polynomials that
cause us to be true we have to actually
get our hands on these polynomials so
let me give you one very simple specific
way of sampling polynomials that we have
reason to believe provides us with some
hardness okay so what are we gonna do
our polynomials will simply be sums of
monomials with certain coefficients okay
recall again that the number of
monomials index H for the polynomial
that is n to the one post Epsilon okay
the coefficients were just going to
sample ID from plus one minus one so to
keep things simple let's do it that way
and the number of monomials that we will
have in every polynomial the size of
this summation which is the size of the
set s of H in this notation is gonna be
some end to the row okay and concretely
think of Rho as being something like
point four so n to the point four okay
and epsilon is point one so this is how
we sample our polynomials we pick n to
the point four monomials at random
multiple inner monomials we picked off
coefficients uniformly from plus one
minus one and that's it that's our
polynomial okay and now I am asking that
would the specific set of polynomials
with a specific way of choosing this
planted solution is it hard for the
adversary to recover the planted
solution and more generally what kind of
hardness is present from such kind of
polynomials okay
and indeed we're conjecturing this this
is hard and this is going to be like the
starting point
the assumption that I'm going to tell
you about momentarily okay so of course
the first question we should ask is wait
a second we have this very problematic
algorithm the sum of squares algorithm
that broke the degree two case what
about that so this is something that is
that is nice that we can say that in
some new work with Barak with Baz I use
and probation court re we can actually
prove a lower bound that rules out sum
of squares attacks for this specific
conjecture
so specifically looking at this
particular class of polynomials this
particular way of choosing the the
plaintiff solution we can actually prove
that sum of squares algorithm will not
be able to well not be able to break it
and this is important because the sum of
squares algorithm first of all is the
main you know boogeyman that we've faced
with regard to previous attempts in this
form in crypto but more generally the
sum of squares algorithm was a very
powerful technique that has sort of
felled a number of important
approximation problems that have come up
in the approximation algorithms
literature where sum of squares gives
the best known results and there's a
whole industry in the stock fox
community investigating sum of squares
algorithms lower bounds as as providing
significant evidence for hardness at
least in other scenarios so so that's
you know that this is one good thing
that we can use to get some to get some
some confidence and we might be onto the
right track here okay um nevertheless
you know absolutely this is just the
beginning you know we want to posit
these natural conjectures we want more
crypt analysis both theoretical and
experimental
and this is an ongoing effort and you
know I definitely want all of your help
that's one of the objectives of giving
talks like this is that we want to be
able to gain confidence in these simple
conjectures also the week and then use
them graphically okay and there's a big
target on our backs also right so now we
have multiple crypto and your papers
that would be broken if you can break
this assumption so please try your best
to do so I mean a good question
absolutely is that reason why you why
you describe this in terms of degree
four polynomial supposed to degree three
is it just you know it's just for it's
just for simplicity if you had asked me
to please open up other things that I'm
gonna be saying in in a moment and tell
you how we actually do it then it's
easiest for me to show that in the do
before case I won't have time to do that
anyway but that's the reason so that I
would be able to just just know you know
I'll mention it later on though thanks
for asking the question I will briefly
mention why I was picking at week four
right now but there are similar such
families when we can define the degree 3
degree 5 any constant degree for which
that same lower bound will actually
apply okay but just for concreteness I'm
looking at two before here yeah thanks
sure okay so great so I do want to point
out we already have a very natural
conjecture this is a super-nice
conjecture you know please try to break
it let's let's see if there's a hardness
present here okay unfortunately this is
not enough to get obfuscation as all
sort of also already kind of alluded to
by Rachel earlier we will need something
to do with lwe here as well and and I'm
going to talk about that now
I also want to mention that in addition
to the new assumption I'm gonna be
talking about we're also going to be
assuming sub-exponential security of
standard LW e and s X th over by linear
groups but those are much more well
studied problems I'm not going to talk
any more about those in this talk all
right
so without further ado let's go straight
to the actual assumption so we all know
lwe
let me just set up some parameters so
I'm just gonna you know I picked these
parameters earlier so I could reuse them
so let P be a end of the point for that
prime will at Chi be a discrete Gaussian
centered at zero with standard deviation
n and that gives us you know the natural
way of sampling algebra samples with you
know AI being sampled uniformly from ZP
from from Z my P and with dimension and
the 0.4 and then you know we either get
this elder Liu example where it's a dot
S Plus e or random and you know LM you
ask that this looks pseudo-random right
mod p so again I wish that we could
build io from this we do not know how to
do that and we need to add a little bit
of complexity and the main idea is just
the following that in addition to these
lwe samples that the adversary typically
gets when we're talking about lwe we're
also going to give the adversary the
output of these polynomials evaluated on
these guys so the only thing I really
switched around here was the error
distribution here I'm talking about it
was quick Gaussian really earlier I was
talking about uniform from minus 10 to n
but that's really the only change that
I've made and another important point
here right is that we are giving out in
this situation and the 1 plus epsilon
evaluations of these polynomials on this
error vector e right so information
theoretically the error vector is being
revealed by these by these evaluations
the polynomials so what we're asking for
here is that despite that despite that
that is true because of the
computational hardness that we expect to
be present from looking at these
evaluations over the over the rationals
we nevertheless want there to be some
security in the elder Lewis setting and
exactly what do I mean this is the exact
new assumption the version I'm
presenting here is from the work with
iuj Rachel and Matt and then also and
then this this new simplest version is
from the later version with high ocean
Rachel where again we have our prime
which is end to the point four bits in
length we have our secret ass which is
also in dimension and the 0.40 error
Eric our errors you won at the en chosen
from this error distribution and now
what we'll do is we'll look as I just
mentioned as at the lwe distribution
this AI comma a dot s + e together with
this leakage does this the evaluations
of polynomials on the planted solution e
on that's error vector e which is now
the planted solution and what we'll look
at in addition to this is another
distribution which is exactly the same
as what we had before the only
difference is I'm going to add some
small perturbations to these outputs of
the polynomials that I mentioned okay
and the perturbations will be very small
there'll be bounded by let's say again
and at the point for just for to make
things simple and what we ask is that
there's a little bit of
indistinguishability between these two
distributions meaning that no efficient
adversary can distinguish between D 1
and D 2 with advantage we'll say greater
than 99% or more precisely as I you she
was alluding to it could be 1 minus 1
over lambda but just to keep things
simple let's talk about 99% and and
again I want to emphasize that this is a
very weak assumption from that point of
view in the sense that even if there
isn't a bet there's an adversary that
can distinguish between these two
distributions with probability 99% but
no adversary can distinguish is probably
99.1 percent then
sumption would be true okay so that's
all we need from the assumption to get
things to work and why is it that we can
handle you know such a week looking
assumption with regard to advantage is
exactly because of what I use talked
about right so when we use this kind of
assumption
together with techniques that Rachel was
we're talking about was talking about
then we would get an Effie scheme that
would also have some sort of like
ninety-nine point or one percent
security and then we would be able to
apply the security amplification
theorems that I use just mentioned to
get it to amplify from that all the way
to functional encryption for circuits
which then we could use to get all the
way to i/o okay so yes so in the
previous version of this that I've seen
maybe from J LMS you also had in these
polynomials aside from the error terms
you had is to see extra variables which
were secret yes absolutely
those were I mean since those who had
never leaked at all since they were
always in the exponent they were helping
with security right and in earlier
versions we really needed that like that
was something that was being used to be
able to sort of make things work but now
we've been able to simplify it further
and I want to make clear the reason
we've done that is not for security so
the point is that indeed we can add two
more variables that don't get leaked at
all and now that's all we actually for
security but my objective our objective
here is to come up with the simplest
assumption that is plausible that we
think is sufficient so that's why I've
done that so it could be that adding
those I mean so if it turns out that you
know this is somehow problematic we
could go back to adding those and then
we do have more freedom room over here
with the techniques of use about so far
in the previous works and also in
newer works but the objective is
simplicity
yeah sure sure yeah I was just wondering
why you took them out so yeah it's a
conscious choice just to make it simple
absolutely this is the assumption right
and one really the the main one of the
main problems existed in our field you
know for for building IO is that just
writing down the assumption that was
needed usually very complicated it takes
a long time so I really want to minimize
the number of variables minimize number
of things that are in the PC I'm a bit
confused here something very basic
why 99 percent and we know this would be
equivalent to in the same
distinguishability oh wait there's
something else going on here because we
know that the key just amplify harvester
so while an environment all equivalent
if they're just in this huge relative
distributions okay right so first I want
to mention that as I use talk about
although you have time to sort of get
into the to the real nitty gritty
details the security amplification
theorem here is quite non-trivial it's
not something that is straightforward by
any means there are a number of things
that have to be done to allow us to do
this so I want to mention that that that
these distributions are officially
generated these yeah these are all until
the ones that are on the screen right
all right so then just like you know
crypto 101 I mean it's a you know 99% is
the same is then you have the constant
no no no no no it's not so sorry any
other constant actually no even that's
not true so no it really does matter
what we write here and let me make a
couple of observations
first of all note that as Rachel
mentioned earlier because the output of
these polynomials are polynomially
bounded right and these adversarial /
nations are also polynomial there will
be a you know 1% distinguisher okay
there will be not 1% it'll be like
someone over and to the something
distinguisher right there is actually a
non-negligible distinguisher between d1
and d2 that follows just from the fact
that the sizes of these of the outputs
are polynomial so the fact that we need
some kind of amplification is inherent
here so I assume you're then assuming
there's some bounded number of samples
that you get because you know otherwise
they can just amplify if I 1% if you
just talk about 7 or some of these 3
indistinguishability distributions to
the 1 plus epsilon so I guess it's a it
is bounded and that yeah right so that
is also a point that we have to we have
to make we have to look at the
parameters carefully to make sure that
we have the kind of linearity that we
need um right
but but I also I'm also just taking
issue with the premise of what you're
saying it's not obvious how you can
amplify an adversary in this situation
right the point is if you give me an
adversary that can distinguish let's say
with probability 1 percent I don't know
that that gives you an address that can
distinguish each probability two percent
right so here it really does depend on
where exactly that boundary sits and by
making the assumption so weak that we
would be happy with an adversary that
could distinguish it even probably 99
percent is important for you know
gaining confidence in the assumption
well what you say makes sense when they
bound the number of samples because if
it's just I press a button I get another
sample then I can definitely take an
adversary this thing which is one
percent
yes absolutely yep it's definitely yeah
I know I know I hear now I understand we
were saying earlier and you're
definitely right obviously we are
talking about a bounded number of
samples and I guess if it were unbounded
you could just linearize and solve so
yeah it's really important that the
number of samples so so what's I guess
maybe the way to say it's what's in
english' bill is is the two
distributions which have some and you
know into the 101.1 samples
yes yes absolutely and and I'm happy for
all the questions but I if it's okay for
me to okay excellent so so first I want
to mention that despite the fact we've
added all this lwe stuff here the really
the most plausible way we have to attack
this problem is still actually by trying
to break the polynomial inversion
problem that I mentioned earlier and why
is that it's because it's actually very
hard to make use of this lwe stuff that
is being given or so it seems let me
talk to you a little bit about what we
thought about so as you as shred I just
alluded to you know the first and often
most deadly foe for those of you who
have you know tread this path like I
have or we're trying to look at parent
assumptions they're just linearization
attacks so here the parameters really
matter and it's very important that
we've set parameters the way that we
have to make sure that there aren't
linearization attacks we can't just take
for example our degree for monomials and
replace them all with linear lean like
just with new variables and nevertheless
solve the system of equations so so
we've looked at that very carefully
that's the best that I can tell you and
we're not aware of an earlier ization
attacks and again stuff has been
published for a while and no one has
found them so we're definitely very
aware of that and thought about it but
we're not aware of an alien reservation
attacks
yeah really quick question if I may so
the the Assumption qlr degree for
polynomials and there are public degree
for polynomials or completely doesn't
they can be chosen at random and then
they're published once and for all
okay sounds good yeah
and again I'm just giving you one
distribution because I want to make
things very concrete especially for the
Crypt analysts in the audience who I
really want to try to attack this but we
do have flexibility we do have
significant flexibility and how we
choose these polynomials okay all right
so so what can we think about here how
can we potentially make use of this
elderly information well one thing we
can think about is by going back to
equations mod P right so you know if we
have all the Blooey samples we can
observe that we can write the errors as
being you know bi - they ipod s my P and
therefore we'll end up with polynomial
equations in s over mod P right so we
also have to make sure and that's why we
had like point four and point one like
these parameters matter that once we do
this once we turned them into equations
over S which remember was only n to the
point four dimensional I still need to
make sure that there's no linearization
attack and with the parameters we've
chosen we do in fact guarantee that and
you know we can try to think how can we
solve these equations block P
efficiently and again there is a long
history of work here the only thing I'll
mention that we can say right now is
initial observation where if we look at
for example Grosvenor business attacks
on these kinds of polynomials then with
the parameters that we've chosen it
would still yield a sub-exponential
attack complexity under a non-trivial
assumption an assumption that these
polynomials that we end up with as
written here are semi-regular they have
the same irregularity property which is
just a conjecture that is typically made
for for analyzing grow grow based stacks
in many settings is that true
unclear in general it's a huge open
question to be able to prove some
arrogance any irregularity of any
particular family of polynomial
equations might be but but that's a
common assumption that's made and in
that case we would be able to show that
the grimmest attack would still be sub
exponential in complexity again this is
just the beginning of work in this area
please help us attack these things this
is like one avenue for attack let me do
one more question the size of s the
dimension of s is how does it relate to
end how should I think about it it's n
to the point four in the example that
I'm giving and degree four polynomial
degree four polynomial yes okay and
again that is important right we have to
make sure that in addition facts don't
occur and and that's why we're choosing
them in this way here and that was also
by the way straight to answer to kind of
come back to your question you know the
reason why we were able to get rid of
those additional variables we used to
have in the function is by being very
careful with these kind of parameter
choices when it came when it comes to
the the choice of row okay and there are
tons of open questions here one of the
most fascinating ones is are there is
there any intelligent way to make use of
this debris for or in general constant
degree leakage with actual lattice
reduction attacks and it's fair to say
that we have no idea houses an attack
would work and you know the idea but the
bomb look is is straightforward this is
the flattest based reduction is
essentially about linear algebra and
it's just unclear how can we make use of
higher degree information in any
intelligent way with a lot of space
reduction techniques I have no idea I
thought about it and I would love for
you all to think about it and you know
another thing that is open if you just
come back to this more basic question of
just can we do polynomial
inversion is for example can we go to
the world mound ruling out gradient
descent right
we definitely have experimental evidence
for this we've tried gradient descent
and it doesn't work when you go beyond
degree to experimentally you know but
that's that's just experiments it
doesn't it doesn't tell us what is the
asymptotic behavior very precisely
and surprisingly you know even though
someone could have asked this question
in the time of Newton um it is an open
question we don't know any way of
proving lower bounds for grading descent
this is a beautiful question that I
would love to for someone to think about
and then other evidence of attacks or
other evidence of hardness would be
great maybe from a physics perspective
you know physical physicists have looked
at hardness of various some problems
that arise in their in their domains
been bearish turistic waves may be those
kinds of heuristics can apply to our
setting as well and I again want to
mention that this is you know now
published multiple crypto Yorker papers
it's a big juicy target for crypt
analysis please try to break it and of
course the big open questions here there
are many of them what I've talked about
so far is inherently about using these
kinds of pseudo random objects over the
integers can we somehow use lwe but now
in combination with boolean PR geez
instead of PR DS over the integers and
still be able to use it to get IO I
think that would be really interesting
we can do it why is that just because
they've been studied more yeah because
it's been studied more so even though
it's really exciting I think it's really
fun and cool to think about hardness
over the integers you know we do have
much more years of evidence of hardness
for boolean piarc used even with low
degree polynomials that are getting
those impurities so that would be cool
to be able to nevertheless exploit that
to be able to get an IO construction can
we somehow separate lwe from a
polynomial hard assumption can I have an
assumption where I just assume lwe
and then separately a polynomial
inversion assumption that would be
awesome
excellent open question and then I've
already promised at least $1,000 that
I'm out of my bank account um for an
actual construction of I have from other
gluey is the big the big white whale
here which we would love to solve and
there are these lower bounds right that
about you know how you cannot get are
you from all-or-nothing primitives and
therefore lwe is unlikely right I think
that's an over an over interpretation of
the lower bound in the sense that all of
these bootstrapping techniques are
highly non black box and the particular
kinds of non black box techniques that
are ruled out with the lower bounds that
currently exist are limited so given
that we're already doing lots of non
black box stuff I don't see that as
being particularly good evidence that I
hope they should be hard to do or should
be impossible to do at all actually I
just will have to use we're already
doing that yes so I was going to end
with my with my garden slide um just to
talk about the importance of new
assumptions in crypto but since we're
out of time I'll just leave it up here
and end here thanks so much thank you so
this is the last talk of the day I mean
we can just ask questions once so
there's one what one still question that
is on the on the chart will be just
really became semi regularity be tested
experimentally and as his business
question so the answer is not
satisfactorily yet it's something that
we're trying to do right now if you're
interested then please talk to me I
would love to
or comments or other people as well we
again the evidence that we could whether
we would be able to achieve
experimentally would be limited but but
it would still be something and we're
doing and we need so again both at just
just just just to look for people don't
know what that means bow would that mean
well it means we could just set up these
equations and Bart running grow nervous
right now these algorithms do take a
long time but we can run them for
certain settings and then just see what
is maximum degree of the intermediate
computations that we see during that
mutation and then compare that with
what's predicted under the assumption of
some regularity and not as something
that okay alright thank you all the
speakers and the other session chess so
we'll continue tomorrow thank you